since we are in New York I thought I'd
invite a very familiar voice he's the
voice of the New York subway system you
hear him you hear him on all the trains
you hear him on the subway platforms and
I wanted him to come out and just say hi
please welcome charlie poet
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Charlie you have an iconic voice lay it
on us you know we want to hear lay it on
us
stand clear of the closing doors please
that's fantastic but Charlie Charlie
this is New York
that's way too polite if you don't mind
say it like a real New Yorker just once
you want to hear that I got staying
clear of the closing doors please
or don't let's be honest a guy with his
head stuck in the subway doors would be
pretty friggin funny it's all we had eat
before you go I thought of a couple of
other phrases I've always wanted to hear
in your voice do you mind can you do it
right now next stop funky town
hey girl you up just a reminder we're
all one day closer to those big closing
doors in the sky if you're taking this
eastbound 7 train to Citi Field let me
save you the trip the Mets lose stand
clear of the closing doors and stand
clear of your mind closing its doors
because life is a circle time is
infinite and you have both never existed
and always exist
[Applause]
you